hello everyone I am Isabel Zimmerman if
you're in this room you're probably
looking for a talk called holistic mlops
or better science
hopefully
um so I work for a company called posit
uh if you are familiar with the company
called rstudio
last week I think we were our studio we
are now posit uh really embracing the
extension to all the beautiful things
we've done for the art ecosystem into
python
foreign
but a little bit more about me uh this
is me this is my dog toast
um I am a full-time open source software
engineer I
hello
um
but I'm also a grad student currently
um so I get to you know spend my small
amount of free time playing games like
Mario Kart if you're not quite familiar
with Mario Kart it's pretty low stress
um in theory unless you have friends
like mine uh and you get to drive little
go-karts around there's a famous track
called rainbow road so this is me this
is toast we're playing Mario Kart
together
but maybe more importantly for this talk
what is ml Ops Emma lops is a set of
practices to deploy and maintain machine
learning models in production reliably
and efficiently
and these practices can be hard when I
started I was at a company where I was
deploying machine learning models on
kubernetes systems which is really like
the worst of Both Worlds you're trying
to deploy model systems and you're
working with kubernetes
um and I felt really I I had data
science skills and the tools that were
was using they weren't quite built for
people like me
um they were built for maybe a cloud
architect
uh and I didn't think that I should have
to have maybe all the knowledge of a
cloud architect or a systems engineer to
be able to at least get my models to a
point where um a devops team could
easily deploy them
uh real quick has anybody in here like
deployed a model before by a show of
hands
okay and keep your hands up if that was
just a delightful experience like best
best moment of your day okay so maybe my
hypothesis was correct
uh I ended up moving career paths to
build a package called vetiver that is
built for data scientists to help you
guys and me selfishly deploy models a
little bit easier
and if I think about
um you know who's making models it's a
lot of times people uh write R code and
people writing python code this is
actually a package in both Python and R
so you can download it from cran or from
Pi Pi
foreign
but when I was learning about data
science I learned about a data science
life cycle that looked kind of like this
so you start by collecting data you
understand and clean the data using
tools like the Tidy verse or data table
if you're in r or if you aren't python
it's things like pandas numpy Suba
from there you're going to train and
evaluate your model once again in R
that's you're going to be using tools
like tidy models and carrot uh in Python
that's things like psych learn or pi
and you know when you're learning about
these things you learn about all of the
best practices for making machine
learning models and all the best
practices for doing your data um data
analysis work and these tools have done
such a fantastic job of uh having these
best practices kind of baked in that you
might not even think about it
so if we look at data science code uh
it's maybe some of this is more
important than others for this talk but
this line four appears in most places uh
if you are making a model and that's
setting that random state or are you
setting your seed and this is to ensure
reproducibility uh and it's something
that we've all kind of accepted we know
this is a best practice
and it's like it's in code like we see
it all the time uh this is a little data
set looking at predicting light counts
on YouTube
um if the ad is funny if it shows the
product
the data looks something like this
and when we get to modeling this data
before we make our model we know that
we're going to split this into a
training and a test set uh we're going
to make sure we're not giving our model
the answers to the questions before
we're training it this is built into the
code this is a best practice we know
about this
and I'll show you one more
um you know that you need to choose the
right feature engineering for your job
so we need to like do an ordinal encoder
here
um and use our random force regressor uh
you're gonna put this in a scikit-learn
pipeline um to kind of package up
everything that's being fitted all at
once and we know things like this we are
data scientists
this is best practice
but then you get to your first job and
you realize there's more to life than
setting random seeds and splitting
things into training and test sets uh
there's questions like okay so I trained
my model how am I going to hand it over
to my teammates like am I gonna email
them a joblib file hopefully not um
maybe you'll use GitHub uh but then what
about what happens when you have to put
this inside of some sort of application
are you gonna copy and paste this code
into your application again hopefully
not
um and what happens when you need to
make sure your model is continuing to
perform well a month a year five years
from now
the the world is broader than the scope
that you know at least I first learned
in school
and this is really important because if
you develop models you should probably
operationalize them and this means a lot
of different things to a lot of
different people but in general I think
um we can kind of agree that the
business value of models usually occurs
when it's outside your local environment
so there's more to this cycle and this
is what vetiver aims to help out people
or help people with
um especially learning uh people who are
learning to deploy inversion and monitor
a model
okay so that was enough data science
we're back to Mario Kart now
um when you log into Mario Kart or open
up your little game uh you realize
there's different game modes if you want
to just learn the handling and drive
around at a leisurely play Pace you can
go at 50 CC's if you want to up the ante
you like kind of got it figured out you
can go 100 cc's if you know all of the
game like you're super ready for this
like blazing fast drifting around
corners you're going 150 cc super fun
but you enjoy it at every level
um and you kind of like you can play it
at every level and you get all the good
Mario Kart stuff
and we're going to think about model Ops
in the same way some things are simpler
like it's a little bit slower it's your
50cc model Ops um and we'll speed up as
we go along
so we'll start with versioning when
people are thinking about versioning
normally it's kind of um in the context
of git and we actually version a lot of
things very often and mostly vary badly
this is possibly a familiar scenario you
build your model and you have it saved
somewhere and it's named model because
we're creative uh and then you do some
more training and get some new data and
you have your final model
and then you have I think you guys know
where this is going a few more
iterations of what this model actually
ends up being
um and we can see this doesn't work for
one model it doesn't scale for one model
and it lacks context between each
iteration
so
I'm missing it this would be an image of
a hex sticker that has a little pin on
it because
um
nope not yet
here we go versioning is helpful because
it helps your models live in a central
location it helps them be discoverable
by your team
um because you don't want to go like
play hide and go seek with your models
uh and in a perfect world it would be
awesome if these could also load right
into memory so we're not trying to go
somewhere download it job live load
open your model like and then go like if
we could just have one line and our
model is in our Jupiter notebook and
like we're ready to Raw rock and roll
that would be like perfect
and this is where we look at our pins
package this is also something that was
developed by our team it's also
something that's available are in Python
and it helps you with these demands that
our List of Demands we have
so what does it look like to use pens
the core piece of pins is the idea of a
model board so we can think of this as a
place for your model to be stored it
doesn't actually just have to be a model
this can be an arrow file um it could be
Json it could be a CSV
um and there's other data types if
you're an r and it actually can cross
between languages if it's a compatible
type which is also super cool
um but anyway it's a place for things to
be stored and here we have a temporary
board
but it could also be uh on S3 on Azure
it would just be like board underscore
GCS uh or our personal or posits product
called connect
so there there's a spot for your model
to be stored and what about the model
part
so that's going to be going into
something
um called a vetiver model when you first
train your model there's actually a lot
of information in there
um that could be leveraged later uh to
give you a more robust deployment so
you're going to put in your pipeline
that you've trained earlier and we're
going to give it a name called ads and
that's it
you can write your vetiver PIN or
whatever pin right your model to your
model board and it's versioned
that kind of helps out with your um
scale part you know it's stored
somewhere else but what about the
context
if we're looking at the metadata we can
see there's a bunch of information we
can see like the like when it was
created there's a hash we can see the
file name it's a job Loop file what kind
of model it is and a few required
packages or whatever else you want to
put in the metadata
and I did promise that this looks the
same in Python and r
so on python we're making our ORD we're
making our vetiver model writing our
model to our board
on the python side we are making our
board making our vetiver model and
writing our vetiver model to our board
this is super useful for teams that are
bilingual in like the r python sense
um so there's less you know cognitive
load when you have to context switch
between languages
so that's at 50cc's we have our model
versioned but what if we want to up the
ante just a little bit
it's super helpful later on down the
road if you know what your input data
should look like
uh this is just saving a little piece of
data to better debug later when things
go wrong it allows you to have better
error messages you can kind of peek into
your vetiver model and realize like oh I
have extra columns here or whatever
um like you wouldn't really make a
puzzle if you don't have the image of
what the puzzle looks like that sounds
like Madness and very difficult to piece
together later this is the same concept
and uh this is the exact same code we
were looking at earlier we have one
extra argument and that is p-type data
for Prototype data and we're going to
feed in a little bit of the X training
data it's going to be like a zero row
data frame
um that's going to be translated into a
pedantic base model if you know what
those are
and then your deployment later
understands what uh the data should look
like when it's coming into your model
which is very useful because sometimes a
real world doesn't look the same as what
uh exists in your training set
so then we have our like beautifully
virgin model we have some p-type data
saved and then we want to think maybe a
little bit more holistically about who
this model is impacting we want to make
not only good models statistically but
good models ethically
um also good documentation uh model
cards were created by a team at Google
uh it's kind of like writing down a
recipe for your model but also giving a
lot of other context you will never know
as much about something especially in
the modeling world as when you're
working on it at that moment uh you can
think that you're going to remember all
of these like silly little intricacies
that you thought would be common sense
but I promise you I do this on tests as
grad a gradstorm like oh that makes
perfect sense I'll never forget that uh
and then I realize do model cards give
you an explicit place to write
everything down that you've been
thinking about
so we've seen this vetiver pin write a
few times but what I sneakily have been
hiding from you all is that this gives
you a little pop-up warning
um that says model cards provide a
transparent responsible reporting use
the vetiver quarto template as a place
to start
and of course like anyone else uh when
you get any information you just copy
and paste the code and you run it and
this will give you a quarto document
quarto is a open source framework for
technical publishing uh my slides are
written in quarto if you are at a talk
today by Daniel Chen he also hello
Daniel
um he also gave a talk about Corto uh it
is the coolest thing ever I could go on
a whole tangent about like how much I
love this
um so this creates a template there's a
little bit of like parameters at the top
where you can write in your PIN
information
um and then it'll generate a document
that looks something like this and
anything we can automate for you is
automated so things like it's a psychic
learn pipeline it's using four features
um if you have a version it'll say like
version X was created at this time uh
and you can add some information about
you and your team
and if you scroll down you'll be able to
see a printout of your p-type
um you know it's a looking at different
houses like the type square foot bed
bath uh and some quantitative analysis
about how your model is performing this
is all actually just code even though it
looks as beautiful as it does so you can
add any custom plots you want or any
custom information
and if you scroll all the way down at
the bottom this is where it gets kind of
interesting especially for me when I
want to think about model fairness
um and how my model is affecting people
and you might think uh like oh
my model does not have any ethical
challenges it's predicting YouTube likes
like that's okay I'm not going to write
anything down here
um and for that I would say there's kind
of two things to think about one maybe
think about asking the people your model
is affecting uh maybe they don't have
the same answer as you do from the
developer's side and two even if you
have um you've done your due diligence
and you've asked everyone you should I
would just kind of leave this blank like
don't delete it uh because any
incomplete information is better than
none at all
uh my dad has a good quote that I think
I like to give to everybody else when
they're thinking about model cards uh
and he said if you haven't written it
down you haven't thought it out so even
though it feels a little bit slower um
and it's like oh what's this girl
talking about for like five minutes
about writing documentation this is
important stuff too
um so I think this is really important
when you're thinking about holistic
what's getting deployed um what are the
impacts of people
all right we have our little heart okay
we have versioned our model and now it's
time to think about moving our model out
into the real world
real world
and
um what is deployment
people have defined this in many
different ways but the way I think about
this is anytime it's not on your laptop
it is deployed uh in vetiver we think of
this uh or mostly do deployments as API
endpoints it's useful because you can
still communicate to your model almost
as if it was in memory that ever has
some helper functions that you can just
do like vetiver.predict give the
endpoint give your data and it'll do the
like Json to
um endpoint back to Json back to data
frame handoff for you so it feels like
your model is right there
it's also useful and will make all your
software engineering friends very happy
because apis are testable so it's quite
robust
so our model should go anywhere outside
of our laptop you can also test these
locally to make sure they're working as
you expect them to and that's by just
creating a vetiver API you put your
vetiver model V inside of it and my API
dot run will get you a local instance
of course we don't want a local instance
that's the whole point of deployment
um so if we're trying to move this
somewhere else
there is a one liner if you're moving it
to our uh system connect and you give it
the connect server uh give it the model
board the name and the version if you
have a version if you don't want to give
a version it'll just find the latest one
maybe less recommended you probably want
a robust version in plates but I'm going
to mess around and find out
and if you're not using connect there is
other ways to move your model around
it's kind of a two-step process one you
want to write an app.pi file and vetiver
right app will help you out with this
it'll make a super small generated
script for you where it's essentially
creating a vetiver model with the board
pen name and version you're looking for
um and then it'll set up the API and
actually a lot of cloud services right
now only need the app.pi file but other
places are interested in maybe a Docker
filed the federal right Docker
um will write that Docker file that will
get you most of the way there for most
deployments it'll read in this app.pi
file that was generated
um it'll peek around for
requirements.text files and you have
these things in hand
um to either deploy yourself uh if you
are on AWS I think you can upload this
directly into ECR and ECS and it kind of
does some Docker magic
um and other places have like a bring
your own Docker file mentality as well
so this is deployment
but we're going to be a little bit more
sophisticated we're going to think about
um where everything is living now
so we have to think we have our model
somewhere we have our rest API somewhere
and we have our local laptop and in a
perfect world our Docker uh container is
as small and skinny as possible makes it
faster makes it cheaper and our model
that we want to iterate on that we want
store all these different versions it's
going to live somewhere else you might
think it would be like nice to save this
in your Docker file
um but that's not quite the case it's
going to get very bloated especially
because you're not versioning one model
you're probably versioning Lots
so let's think about how this is going
to happen
so first when your Docker container
spins up it's going to use that app.pi
file to load the FED over Model start up
the API
um this is one of those holistic like
best practices that vetiver kind of
bakes in for you if you use those two
lines from before most of this is
already happening um unless you're
trying really hard to like do some local
pins model inside the docker container
like you'd have to try to make sure that
this is a very large container
so the docker container is going to peek
in to your model it's going to load it
up and then you can communicate to this
Docker container just like any other API
uh you can post to it you can interact
with it and it feels great
but then you know you might have to do
some analysis on your model you might do
some monitoring you might have some
weird instance or just any other ad hoc
information that you need to get from
your model and now you don't have to
peek into that Docker container anymore
you can just load it right from your
pins board right into memory and use it
as as expected you can do all your
analysis on your model
and that kind of completes our cycle
here
um we have our
model is versioned with pins it's
deployed it's either running in connect
with a one-liner or you've made a Docker
file to bring it to some other public
cloud
and now it's time to monitor
because once a model is deployed a data
scientist's work is not done
um I do have to say here that monitoring
in this sense is going to be a little
bit different than maybe you're used to
we're not particularly interested in in
this package at looking at like CPU
usage or runtime here we're looking at
statistical methods um so like rsme ma
like all like is your model performing
as well as you uh thought it was or
um expect it to
and vetiver has some helper functions to
help you compute pin and plot metric
metric I'm not gonna give you like two
in depth of these
um but just know they exist they help
you do things like store your metrics
data
um and it handles that awkward like I
have a few days that overlap uh you can
choose if it overwrites um on the last
uh export or not
and a one-liner that helps you plot the
metrics using plotly to get all that
lovely interactivity
okay
and I think this is super important to
say explicitly but you should probably
be monitoring your model if it's
deployed and that's because you know
data science is uh it's a little funky
if things go wrong you don't necessarily
get an error message
um you don't get that big X like cannot
compile things are failing like your
model can continue to give you
um answers even if it's zero percent
accuracy like even if it is the worst
model in existence it will confidently
give you that answer and if you're not
monitoring you might think that answer
is right so it's super important because
if you're not monitoring your model you
are oblivious to decay
and that completes our cycle we can
version deploy and monitor models um
we're ready for that uh school to
Industry uh shift it's scary it's doable
um but there's a lot of ml Ops tools out
there it's a happening space and if you
Google what does the ml Ops landscape
look like uh you get an image that looks
something like this and it's terrifying
um
so what what was I thinking about when I
was building better like why is vetiver
different that's kind of a loaded
question
um but what was I thinking about when
building it
and the first thing I was thinking about
when I was building it is composability
so this is important because I wanted
just a few simple tools that you that
you're able to compose within themselves
to make complex objects
I really only showed you guys two things
today it's the vetiver model in the
vetiver API
um
the vetiver model is you know taking
your trained model in the vetiver API is
making the API but if you wanted to make
an API with many endpoints that's
possible if you wanted to do all of the
crazy
um oh my gosh people do the wildest API
gymnastics this is built off of fast API
so any way you want to extend it that's
compatible with fast API is possible
still so it's composable with itself and
it can also leverage the entire
ecosystem that's around these tools
um and not only is it composable within
itself but it's uh like composable with
maybe desk if you wanted to you know
train with desk because this is ending
just after your model is trained uh it's
supposed to feel kind of like just an
extension of the workflow you already
have
which brings us to our next point
I wanted to make a project that feels
good to use and works with the tools
that you like
um I wanted something that helps kind of
lower the barrier to entry to learning
how to do these things that come after
training a model
but I still wanted people to be able to
use the tools that they liked uh which
is why it's happening after the model is
trained not trying to come earlier in
the workflow
also
uh this has happened before this might
be kind of sacrilegious to say at a pi
data conference but some things are
easier and are than python
um
so pins gives us a great Crossroads to
leverage like the boasts of Both Worlds
uh The Best of Both Worlds
I've had times where somebody else of my
team claims their data and R they can
pin it to a board using arrow and I just
read it in and continue doing my
modeling myself and that's just a really
easy workflow that works for us that I'd
love to share with all of you if you
also deal with art people
um if you have questions uh I'd love to
answer them I'm at the posit Booth uh
right across the hall from here or I can
take questions now
[Applause]
uh I saw it hey yeah hi
yeah this sounds really awesome
it's had a few doubts on the deployment
models So when you say you deploy it I
assume that you want to have a Docker
container
can go down
yeah so the question is
um where are you bringing this model
were you bringing the docker container
really
um and you can bring it to like ECS ECR
uh I'm also looking at we're looking at
like Lambda as well anywhere that bring
has a like bring your own Docker
container mentality uh which most public
clouds do and they'll have the logs
there as well uh vetiver does not do uh
logging for things like CPU metrics or
anything like that
yes
yeah thank you
um
does the package have
a perspective or opinion on how to
create
calculating the evaluation
but is there an opinionated pattern for
how to how to create that feedback the
out of the sample
observations
yeah that is an awesome question the
question was how do we close that
feedback loop of new data back to
monitoring as of right now
um we do not have an opinion on that I
would love to talk to anyone who has
strong opinions on this
um I've been looking around on different
dags uh to figure out how to get that
easier
um so I guess
best answer don't know right now um
there are ways to use dags because it is
so lightweight uh to build out that
framework I'm sure you could use things
like air flow I'm saying that
tentatively uh someone else wants to
chat with me about this that would be
awesome
yes
yeah that would be kind of up to the
user
um to depend on how you want to pin or
save those different metrics uh we're
able to like store them in different
pins
um and then we like bring new metrics in
and then continue to like store that on
that
um model board your library is a dog and
technology
so yeah if you're making a prediction
um it'll come back as a data frame so
wherever you're going to store that data
frame
um if you want to store it in a pin that
would be
a pretty like lightweight workflow to
continue to use that ecosystem yep
are there any tools
yeah you would leverage probably
um there's a lot of packages out there
that's out of the scope of vetiver
um we're looking more at like
um the metrics themselves I know Alibi
has done amazing work I've got to play
around with that package a lot
um that you could plug in as
um
yeah you could plug that in um and then
store it in that metrics as well
and you could pin that along with
um here let me go back
good to do
so at the end of compute metrics metrics
is a data frame um so you could add a
column uh that alibi or another feature
direct detection could add in um just
compose
yeah customizability
um reset or good Island
yeah you can uh use these are
scikit-learn metrics functions anything
that has a y true and a y predict column
um will be able to be used in the
vetiver compute Matrix function
yes
um
endlessly
um so if I understood the question
correctly how would you collaborate on a
Model card yeah
yeah okay so quarto documents are just
code it looks actually
we're gonna peek at
cursor go
um
if you want to see my slides here they
are uh
this is what a quarter document looks
like
um
and so it is just code it looks kind of
like a Jupiter notebook
uh so if you wanted to use it on git if
you wanted to store it in some other
Central repository uh for everyone to
collaborate on you could
um pass that around and I use it that
way
I used to like
like
that is correct that is one of my
favorite things about
um is you don't have to deal with the
Json weirdness of a Jupiter notebook
um even if you don't have Corto
installed it's still super readable
um and it can execute code chunks uh if
you want to execute code chunks you can
actually embed whole applications
um if you saw the shiny talks yesterday
uh you can embed shiny apps like in your
slides if you wanted to or in that
document uh with a quarto extension
called shiny live
um I think one thing that I really have
loved about kind of spanning this R
python ecosystem because everything in R
works together super well uh you're like
oh I can I want this and I also want to
use this and like how do I put it
together
um
that I think it's super exciting to see
with quarto like you can write python
code you can write our code you can have
applications and it can be a document
and then if you change one line of code
it's also slides or it's a book or it's
a website
um that's my little rant on like
interoperability it's so cool
um but yes Corto is awesome
check it out
any other questions
awesome thank you all for joining
um I'll be out at the posit food if
you're interested
[Applause]